Ilona asks how many hours of sleep do
you normally manage to get to your
schedule how do you avoid burning out
well first
heaven is nine and a half hours
on a day maybe there's a little bit of
rain for some reason even though you
live in the city it's quiet an
occasional car slowly driving by heaven
is getting those nine and a half no
heaven is the first cup of coffee after
the nine and a half hours of sleep yeah
optimal performance wise I like to get
seven or eight hours of sleep I don't
often get that amount of sleep though
and I think the rest is just all mental
I still often pull nights where it's one
to three hours of sleep I frequently
pull all-nighters
maybe an average about 10 to 15
all-nighters a year all have to do with
deadlines and just focus a few
occasional rare beautiful all-nighters
are sort of your soak pad I'm so
passionate about a particular idea they
just can't wait I can't wait to see it
work and I guys stay up all night you
know through noon in the afternoon and
then maybe go to bed early next night
you know go to bed at like 9:00 p.m. or
something like that burn out too you
know what I don't believe I'm a burnout
it's it's not like a I think I think
there's just a voice of laziness that
can be defeated with uh with the sword
of focus perseverance determination and
passion I think I love everything I do I
could wash toilets I could do manual
labor anything I just love it
I love every moment of every day the
sadness the fear all of that that's a
beautiful part of the journey I love it
so to me burnout doesn't even make sense
like what what are you burning out from
even the concept of burnout is something
that I love so like if you feel like
you're burning out that that's beautiful
too that's part of the human experience
I love that whole thing and when you're
passionate about everything what
hell doesn't anything the burnout kind
of says like I'm I think because I've
known close close people to me that have
suffer from depression
I think depression is the sort of
actually like clinical depression is
kind of the experience that I I see as
beyond the kind of thing that I'm
talking about which is it's really
you're in a place where nothing is
meaning but to me I have never
experienced
a moment where something is not rich of
meaning and I think David Frost for
David Foster Wallace said you know the
key to life is to be unborn
meaning it's impossible to make you
bored of anything you do and I'm unborn
is it
I got a Russian sort of sad suffering
face most of the time but I'm actually
happy on the inside I'm like a like a
Kiwi ugly on the outside sweet and
glorious on the inside again that that's
one question I'm not even answering
correctly okay
you